[Aplausos]
roberts vicepresidenta harris
o será pelosi líder summers firma con el
vicepresidente pensé y mi invitado
distinguido del pueblo estadounidense
este es el día de eeuu este es el día de
la democracia el día de la historia y la
esperanza de renovación de resolución ha
sido crisol para todo eeuu y eeuu ha
sido prueba de nuevo y eeuu se ha puesto
al día con el desafío hoy celebramos el
triunfo no de un candidato sino de una
causa de la causa de la democracia el
pueblo la voluntad del pueblo ha sido
escuchada y la voluntad del pueblo ha
sido acatada hemos aprendido una vez más
que la democracia es preciosa la
democracia también es frágil y a esta
obra compañeros la democracia ha
prevalecido
[Aplausos]
así que en estos terrenos sagrados donde
hace unos pocos días la violencia buscó
sacudir los cimientos del capitolio nos
hemos reunido como una nación bajo dios
indivisible para llevar a cabo la
transición pacífica del poder como hemos
hecho por más de dos siglos a medida que
miramos al futuro de nuestra manera
única estadounidense incansable osada y
optimista y nos enfilamos hacia ser la
nación que sabemos que podemos ser y que
debemos ser le agradezco a mis
predecesores de ambos partidos
presidentes acá les agradó les agradezco
desde el fondo de mi corazón y yo sé
y yo conozco la resiliencia la
resiliencia de nuestra constitución y la
fortaleza de nuestra nación así como el
presidente cárter con el que hablé
anoche que no pudo estar con nosotros
hoy pero a quien saludamos por sus
servicios de toda una vida
[Aplausos]
acabo de tomar el juramento sagrado que
cada uno de esos patriotas ha tomado el
juramento que fue
que fue dicho primero por george
washington pero la historia
estadounidense no depende de ninguno de
nosotros ni de algunos de nosotros sino
de todos nosotros
en nosotros el pueblo que buscamos una
unión más perfecta esta es una gran
nación somos personas buenas y a lo
largo de los siglos a lo largo de la
lucha sea en paz en guerra hemos llegado
muy lejos pero todavía tenemos que
llegar más lejos seguiremos haciendo
presión con urgencia porque hay mucho
por hacer
en este invierno de preocupaciones hay
muchas posibilidades hay mucho por
reparar hay mucho por restaurar mucho
por sanar mucho por construir y mucho
por ganar muy pocas personas en la
historia de nuestra nación han tenido
tantos desafíos han encontrado una época
más desafiante más difícil que la época
en la que estamos ahora un virus de una
vez en un siglo que está causando
destrozos en el país ha tomado tantas
vidas en un año
más que todas las pérdidas en por eeuu
en la segunda guerra mundial millones de
trabajos han sido perdidos cientos de
miles de negocios han cerrado una llanta
una búsqueda de la justicia racial que
ha pasado tantos años haciéndose nos
mueve el sueño de la justicia para todos
no será diferido nunca más
[Aplausos]
es un una petición de supervivencia que
viene del dependerá como tal un llanto
que no puede ser más de espera más
desesperado ni más claro ahora el
crecimiento del extremismo político la
supremacía blanca el terrorismo
doméstico que debemos confrontar y
venceremos
para superar todos estos desafíos y
restaurar el alma asegura en el futuro
de eeuu requiere mucho más que palabras
requiere lo más elusivo en cada
democracia la unidad unidad
y en otro enero en 1863 abraham lincoln
firmó la proclamación de emancipación
cuando firmó este papel el presidente
dijo y citó si mi nombre queda en la
historia alguna vez deberá ser por este
acto y toda mi alma está en este acto
toda mi alma hoy
en este día de enero todavía alma está
acá reunir eeuu unir a nuestro pueblo
unir a nuestra nación y le pido a cada
estadounidense que sea una bien esta
causa
[Aplausos]
para enfrentar a los enemigos que hemos
enfrentado con odio extremismo
y legalidad violencia la enfermedad el
desempleo la desesperanza enfrentaremos
todo esto con la unidad podemos hacer
grandes cosas cosas importantes podemos
enmendar los errores poner personas a
trabajar en buenos trabajos enseñar a
nuestros hijos en escuelas seguras
superar este virus mortal
podemos recompensar el trabajo y
reconstruir la clase media hacer que
haya salud para todos podemos crear
generar justicia racial y hacer que eeuu
se vuelva de nuevo la fuerza líder del
bien en el mundo yo sé que hablar de
unidad
puede sonar para muchos como una
fantasía terca en esta época sé que las
fuerzas que nos dividen son profundas y
son reales pero también sé que no son
nuevas
nuestra historia ha sido una lucha
constante entre el ideal estadounidense
que todo bajo el que todos estamos
creados iguales y la horrible realidad
del racismo del nativismo del miedo de
la demonización
que nos ha dividido desde hace mucho
tiempo la batalla es perenne y la
victoria nunca está asegurada la guerra
civil la depresión la guerra mundial el
9/11 la lucha el sacrificio el retroceso
siempre nuestras mejores cualidades han
perseverado en cada uno de estos
momentos suficiente de nosotros muchos
de nosotros nos hemos reunido para
llevarnos juntos hacia adelante y
podemos hacer esto ahora la historia la
fe y la razón ha mostrado el camino el
camino de la unidad podemos vernos uno
al otro no como adversario sino como
vecinos podemos tratarnos con dignidad y
con respeto podemos unir fuerzas dejar
de gritar nos bajar la temperatura
sin unidad no hay paz solamente furia
acidez no hay progreso solamente
cansancio sin progreso sin nación
solamente un estado de caos
ese es nuestro momento histórico de
crisis y desafío y de unidad la unidad
es el camino hacia adelante y debemos
enfrentar este momento
como los estados unidos de américa y si
hacemos eso yo garantizo que no o
fracasaremos nunca nunca nunca hemos
fracasado en eeuu
cuando hemos actuado juntos así que hoy
en este momento en este lugar empecemos
de nuevo todos juntos escuche monos de
nuevo uno al otro
veámonos el uno al otro
respetémonos el uno al otro
la política no tiene que ser un incendio
lleno de ira que destruye todo su camino
cada desacuerdo no tiene que ser una
causa para guerra total tiene que ser a
causa de la guerra total y nosotros
debemos rechazar esa cultura en la que
los hechos per se son manipulados e
incluso manufacturados
[Aplausos]
compañeros estadounidenses debemos ser
diferentes eeuu debe ser mejor que esto
y yo creo que eeuu es mucho mejor que
eso miren alrededor de ustedes aquí
estamos a la sombra del tomo del
capitolio como fue mencionado antes
finalizado en medio de una guerra civil
cuando la unión en sí misma estaba
colgando de un pelo y aún así lo
soportamos préval decimos aquí estamos
mirando a este gran molde donde el
doctor king habló de su sueño aquí
estamos donde hace 180 años
en otro momento inaugural miles de
manifestantes intentaron bloquear a las
mujeres valientes que marchaban por el
derecho a votar y hoy marcamos el
juramento de la primera mujer en la
historia estadounidense elegida a la
oficina un cargo nacional vicepresidente
kamala harris no me digan que las cosas
no pueden cambiar
y aquí estamos en frente del cementerio
donde los héroes que dieron su vida
descansan en paz aquí estamos de pie
nosotros apenas días después de que una
multitud pensó que podía usar la
violencia para silenciar la voluntad del
pueblo para detener el trabajo de
nuestra democracia para sacarnos de este
sitio sagrado esto no pasó esto nunca va
a pasar no hoy ni mañana nunca nunca
[Aplausos]
para aquellos que han respaldado nuestra
campaña
me hace humilde la fe que ustedes han
depositado en los otros aquellos que no
nos respaldaron déjenme decir esto
escúchenme a medida que seguimos
adelante mírame a mí miran a mi corazón
si todavía estar en desacuerdo está bien
esa es la democracia eso es eeuu el
derecho al descenso en paz es una de las
salvaguardas de nuestra nación es su
mayor fortaleza escuchen de claramente
el desacuerdo no debe liderar a la de su
nueve llevar a la desunión y yo le
prometo eso ustedes seré presidente para
todos los estadounidenses todos los
estadounidenses
[Aplausos]
y prometo que lucharé tan fuerte por
aquellos que no me respaldaron así como
por aquellos que lo hicieron
[Aplausos]
hace muchos siglos san agustín el santo
de mi iglesia escribió que el pueblo era
una multitud definida por el objetivo
común de su amor definida por el
objetivo común de su amor cuáles son los
objetivos comunes que nosotros estos
días es amamos que nos definen como
estadounidenses creo que sabemos la
oportunidad la seguridad la libertad la
dignidad del respeto el honor y si la
verdad
en los últimos meses y semanas hemos
aprendido de lección dolorosa hay verdad
y hay mentiras mentiras que se dicen en
nombre del poder y el nombre de la
ganancia cada uno de nosotros tiene un
deber y una responsabilidad como
ciudadanos y como estadounidenses
especialmente como líderes los líderes
que han prometido honrar nuestra
constitución y proteger a nuestra nación
defender la verdad y vencer las mentiras
miren
[Aplausos]
yo entiendo que muchos de mis compañeros
estadounidenses ven el futuro con miedo
y yo entiendo que muchos se preocupan
por sus trabajos
pero sabemos que viene después yo les
prometo que lo entiendo
quiero
la respuesta no es entrar a uno mismo
retirarse y entrar en su acciones
competitivas desconfiar en otros que no
parecen conocen o que no obran como uno
porque no reciben la noticia de las
mismas fuerzas que fuentes que unos
debemos terminar esta guerra incivil
camps wood del rojo en contra del azul o
lo rural contra el urbano el
conservadurismo contra el liberalismo
podemos hacer esto si abrimos nuestra
alma en vez de endurecer nuestro corazón
si mostramos algo de tolerancia algo de
humildad y si estamos dispuestos a
defender a ponernos en los zapatos del
otro como mamá decía por un momento
ponernos en sus zapatos
porque ese es el tema sobre la vida no
no hay ningún tipo de contabilidad sobre
lo que hace por uno a veces cuando uno
necesita ayuda pasa pero hay otros días
donde se nos pide ayudar y así es como
debe ser eso es lo que debemos hacer uno
por otro y si funcionamos de esta manera
nuestro país será más fuerte más
próspero estará listo para el futuro y
aún podremos tener desacuerdos
compañeros estadounidenses en el trabajo
que nos vienen vamos a necesitar el uno
del otro
vamos a necesitar toda nuestra fuerza
para perseverar a través de este
invierno tan oscuro en lo que podría ser
el período más de difícil y mortal del
virus debemos ir a la política a un lado
y enfrentar finalmente esa pandemia como
una nación una nación
y yo les prometo esto como dice la
biblia podemos enfrentar una noche
difícil pero la alegría llegará la
mañana
atravesaremos este momento juntos juntos
caballeros damas y caballeros miren
todos los colegas con los que he servido
en la cámara en el senado están acá
todos entendemos que el mundo está
observando observándonos a todos hoy así
que este es mi mensaje a todos los que
están más allá de nuestras fronteras
eeuu ha sido probada y hemos salido más
fuertes de esta prueba
repararemos nuestras alianzas y nos
conectaremos con ellas de nuevo no paren
frente a los desafíos del ayer sino los
desafíos del hoy y del mañana
y lideraremos no solamente con el
ejemplo o con nuestro poder sino por el
poder de nuestro ejemplo
[Aplausos]
seremos un aliado fuerte para la paz el
progreso y la seguridad miren todos
sabemos hemos atravesado muchas cosas en
esta nación mi primer acto como
presidente le quisiera pedir a ustedes
que se unan en un momento de oración
solemne por todos aquellos que hemos
perdido el último año por la pandemia de
esos 400 mil estadounidenses madres
padres esposos esposas hijos e hijas
amigos vecinos colegas nos honraremos a
convertirnos en el pueblo y la nación
que sabemos que podemos y debemos ser
así que les pido que digamos una oración
solemne por aquellos que han perdido sus
vidas y aquellos que han quedado atrás y
por nuestro país
y me amen foxx damas y caballeros ese es
un momento de pruebas enfrentamos un
ataque sobre la democracia y sobre la
verdad un virus devastador una inequidad
que cada vez crece más el racismo
sistémico la crisis climática eeuu en
todo el mundo todos lo sabemos debemos
enfrentar esos desafíos todos tienen
aristas profundas para el hecho es que
los enfrentamos todos a la vez
presentando esta nación con una de las
respuestas una de las posibilidades más
fuertes que hemos tenido pero ahora
tendremos otra prueba vamos a enfrentar
esta prueba juntos es momento de ser
usados y seguir trepidó hay tanto por
hacer y esto es cierto yo les prometo a
ustedes seremos juzgados ustedes y yo
por como resolvamos estas crisis esta
andanada de crisis de nuestra era
pero enfrentaremos la ocasión
dominaremos está ahora complicada
enfrentaremos nuestras obligaciones y se
las pasaremos le pasaremos un mundo
mejor a nuestros hijos creo que ustedes
también creen creo
que lo haremos y cuando lo hagamos
escribimos el siguiente gran capítulo de
la historia de los eeuu de américa la
historia estadounidense una historia que
puede sonar un poco como una canción que
significa mucho para mí y se llama el
himno estadounidense hay un verso que
sobresale al menos para mí y dice eso el
trabajo y las oraciones de este siglo
nos han llevado a este día pues será
nuestro legado que irán nuestros hijos
déjenme dejen que se para en mi corazón
cuando se acabe mis días eeuu eeuu
yo te di lo mejor de mí agreguemos a
esto
nuestros propios nuestro trabajo no son
propios oraciones a esta historia en
curso de nuestra creación si hacemos
esto
cuando nuestros días pasen y se acabó en
nuestros hijos y sus hijos nos dirán que
dieron lo mejor
que hicieron su deber
que sanaron a una tierra herida
y compañeros estadounidenses cierro aquí
donde empecé con este sagrado juramento
ante dios y ante todos ustedes les doy
mi palabra siempre
los amaré de siempre defenderá la
constitución siempre defenderé nuestra
democracia defenderé a eeuu y daré todo
les mostraré todo lo que yo haga en su
servicio no pensaré solamente en el
poder sino las posibilidades no en los
intereses personales sino en el bien
común juntos escribiremos una historia
nueva estadounidense de esperanza no de
miedo de unidad no de división de luz no
de oscuridad una historia de decencia y
dignidad de amor y de sanación de
grandeza de bondad que esta sea la
historia que nos guíe la historia que
nos inspira y la historia que nos cuente
que el momento está por llegar que
respondimos al llamado a la historia que
enfrentamos este momento la democracia y
la esperanza la verdad y la justicia no
murieron bajo nuestra guardia sino que
aumentaron con fuerza que eeuu asegurado
de libertad en casa y defendió y que
está ahí parada de nuevo una vez como un
faro para el mundo eso es lo que le
debemos a nuestros fundadores
y le daremos a la fundación que a las
generaciones que siguen así que con el
propósito y con la resolución nos
enfrentamos de estas áreas de nuestra
era
así que guiados por la fe por la
convicción de votos aún unos por otros y
al país que amamos con todo nuestro
corazón que dios bendiga a estados
unidos y que dios proteja a nuestras
tropas gracias a eeuu
[Aplausos]